Hey, Dragons!
It's me!
I'm Donkeybird!
So, Respawn asked me to define my perfect apex match.
Well, I don't think they've ever watched me play.
Because my definition of fun?
Chaos.
Lots of chaos.
Don't get me wrong.
I love to get my squads back.
But accidents happen.
So, for those of you who like me, If you want to drop in and
pick things up, allow me to introduce to you my main girl,
Mad Maggie, and tell you why she's the best.
I ain't gonna disappoint you.
First off, I mean, look at her.
She's the most badass looking legend.
Her wrecking ball, it's absolutely fucking sick.
I'm just getting started.
And now her balls are even bigger.
I mean, come on.
Who doesn't like big flaming balls?
buzz.
Plus, with double riot drills, you can go max attack in the
final ring.
So now you're like sick.
I'm sold Maggie for Prez 2024.
Or maybe you're not.
Either way, she doesn't give a if you don't like her.
And guess what?
Not her do I.
Travel on me.
Lady, play.
And what's even better is she's free to play.
So jump in and come for us, the Chaos Queens of Apex.
You'll probably get an easy, you